[Música]
y en directo a Vamos hasta Washington
los jueces de la Corte Suprema revisaron
hoy dos demandas contra Google y Twitter
en las que se les responsabiliza por el
contenido que se mueve en sus
plataformas estas empresas se encuentran
blindadas por una normativa que las
libra de ser culpables de lo que
publican los usuarios si estos casos
prosperan los expertos prevén que
podrían cambiar el internet como lo
conocemos saludamos a esta hora en
Washington a nuestro corresponsal
Cristóbal Vázquez Cristóbal muy buenas
noches háblenos de estos dos casos que
ocurrió para que demandaran a estas dos
empresas
el primero de ellos es el caso de
González versus Google Noemí González
una ciudadana estadounidense fue
asesinada en París cuando estaba en un
bar de la ciudad por el estado islámico
la familia entonces demanda a Google
porque según la familia esta plataforma
está red social y sobre todo YouTube que
hace parte de Google pues ayudó a
fomentar el mensaje y ayudó a reclutar
personas a este a estos grupos
terroristas concretamente el estado
islámico y llevaron a que el estado
islámico pues acabara con la vida de
esta ciudadana estadounidense en París
lo que dice la familia concretamente es
que aunque la plataforma social esté
protegida porque no es responsable de lo
que publica en terceros en Google o en
YouTube si es responsable y dice la
familia aquí está la responsabilidad de
YouTube es al diseñar algoritmos que
lleven a que jóvenes otras personas
consuman más contenido que fomente
violencia que fomente terrorismo y que
lleve a estas personas a enlistarse en
estos grupos terroristas el otro caso
que se está viendo aquí en la Corte
Suprema de Justicia es el caso de
Twitter versus Jazmín también era Es un
familiar de otra persona una ciudadana
jordana que fue asesinada en Turquía
también a manos del estado islámico en
un club en un bar de Estambul Y entonces
los familiares en California están
demandando a Twitter porque según ellos
pues Twitter también fomentó No
solamente la expansión del mensaje
terrorista del estado islámico sino
también el reclutamiento al fomentar
contenido para que estos jóvenes pues se
instalan en estos grupos y llevaron a
cabo ataques terroristas hoy se escuchó
el caso de Google versus González y lo
supimos es que los magistrados se ven
confundidos frente al tema Cristóbal
también se vuelve a poner sobre la mesa
a la sección 230 cómo funciona esta
normativa cuéntenos Y cómo estos casos
podrían impactar en ella y además
cambiar el futuro de internet
sí la la sección 230 hace parte del acta
de comunicación decente de Estados
Unidos que se inauguró en 1996 y lo que
dice básicamente es que las plataformas
de redes sociales Twitter Google YouTube
Facebook no son responsables de lo que
allí en estas plataformas publiquen
terceros y pues eso permite entonces que
estas plataformas sean simplemente
intermediarios de mensajes y sean lo que
muchos analistas en Washington dicen
Pues la plataforma de la libertad de
expresión de los estadounidenses y el
mundo libre no estas plataformas
permiten que las personas pues puedan
comunicarse puedan conectar a través de
estos mensajes sin embargo lo que está
en duda acá lo que está argumentando es
que tanta responsabilidad tienes estas
plataformas a la hora de diseñar
algoritmos que fomenten el reclutamiento
y la violencia en Estados Unidos y en el